بعضهم تجاوزها واخرون لازالوا يعيشون
تداعياتها مشاهير عرب وعالميون واجهوا
ازمات كبرى في العام
2023 وكبار غيبهم
[موسيقى]
الرحيل واجه مشاهير عالميون ازمات صحيه في
العام
2023 منهم الممثل الامريكي بروس ويلس الذي
اعلنت عائلته اصابته بنوع من الخرف يسمى
خرف الجبهي الصدغي وذلك في بيان مشترك
لعائله النجم البالغ من العمر
68 عاما كما الغت سيلين ديون مواعيد
جولتها الغنائيه العالميه حتى عام
2024 ومن المحتمل ان تقوم بجوله مره اخرى
حسب ما قال مصدر مقرب من ديون في وقت سابق
من العام لشبكه سي ان ان وكانت ديون قد
اجلت العديد من العروض في ديسمبر 2022 بعد
ان اعلنت اصابتها بمتلازمه الشخص المتيبس
وهي حاله على حد قولها لا تسمح لها
بالغناء بالطريقه التي اعتادت عليها
واحتفى محبو الفنانه الكنديه مؤخرا بظهور
نادر لها اثناء حضورها مباراه في هوكي
الجليد بلاس
فيغاس عربيا وعلى سيره الازمات التي
واجهها مشاهير في العام 2023 قاضت محكمه
فرنسيه بسجن سته اعوام على المغني المغربي
سعد المجرد بتهمه الاغتصاب والاعتداء على
شابه فرنسيه في غرفه فندق بباريس في عام
200 16 وفقا لما نقلته قناه بي ام اف تي
في الفرنسيه المتعاونه مع شبكه سي ان ان
لكن سرعان ما تجاوز لمجرد ازمته وحصل على
اطلاق سراح مؤقت بينما ينتظر الفرج في
الاستئناف بحسب ما اعلن سابقا عبر حساباته
الرسميه على مواقع التواصل وتم تكريمه
مؤخرا في مهرجان ضيافه في
دبي
هموم محلوش بقيان فرح فيوم
ومطلع 2023 صدر الحكم بمعاقبه الفنانه
المصريه منه شلبي بالحبس لمده عام مع
ايقاف التنفيذ وتغريمها 10000 جنيه بتهمه
حيازه جوهر الحشيش المخدر بقصد التعاطي
وذلك حسب ما اكد محاميها محمد بهاء ابو
شقه في تصريحات خاصه لسي ان ان بالعربيه
اعتبر فيها ان الحكم يوازي البراءه بعد
قرار وقف تنفيذ الحبس ودفع الغرامه واواخر
العام حظي الفنان المصري بيومي فؤاد بدعم
تركي ال الشيخ رئيس هيئه الترفيه
بالسعوديه وفنانين سعوديين وذلك بعد حمله
الانتقادات الواسعه التي تعرض لها على
منصات التواصل في مصر مؤخرا والجدل الذي
اثاره حديثه للجمهور السعودي بعد عرض
مسرحيه زواج اصطناعي في موسم الرياض
وانتقاده الضمني لزميله محمد سلام الذي
انسحب من العرض بسبب ما يحدث في غزه من
حقك انك تعتذر عن المصرحيه لكن مش من حقك
انك تغلط في
فنك وخلال العام 2023 غيب الرحيل العديد
من ابرز الفنانين العرب والعالميين ومنهم
الشاعر كريم العراقي الفنانون السوريون
اسامه الروماني شادي زيدان ومحمد قنوع
المخرج السوري هشام شربجي المطرب العراقي
ياس خضر المطرب الكويتي عبد الكريم عبد
القادر الفنانه اللبنانيه نجاح سلام
الفنانين المصريين طارق عبد العزيز واشرف
عبد الغفور ايقونه الروك الامريكيه تينا
تورنر وماثيو بيري احد نجوم السلسله
الكوميديه الامريكيه الشه
كما واجه سلطان الطرب جوج وسوف اصعب فراق
برحيل نجه الاكبر
وديع